على الرغم من ابتساماتهم وضحكاتهم أمام
الكاميرا ، فإن هؤلاء الأطفال لم
يعرفوا حقًا براءة طفولتهم ،
وتقول إنها لا تزال تعاني من كوابيس اليوم
الذي أصيبت فيه بشظية.
يقول والده ، وهو
مقاتل من المتمردين نفسه ، إنهم لم يكونوا على قيد الحياة
، وكانوا ينتظرون فقط الموت ، لكنه الآن
يقول إن لديه أملًا ، لذا يمكنك أن ترى أن هذه
هي في الأساس المنطقة المنزوعة السلاح ، وهي
الحزام الوردي وداخلها من
المفترض أن تكون تركية فقط
من المفترض أن يتخذ الروس والإيرانيون والنظام السوري
مواقعهم بشكل جيد
في الخارج
بعد سنوات من وقف إطلاق النار
ومناطق خفض التصعيد التي فشلت في عقد
مفاوضات بين روسيا وتركيا بشأن
منطقة منزوعة السلاح ، ربما يكون
اتفاقًا على الأقل.  على
المدى القصير ، هناك فرصة
للتعلم بعد المجيء الثاني
الذي سيهيمن على تركيا مغادرة
بلادنا يمكن للمقاتلين المتمردين الاحتفاظ
بأسلحتهم الخفيفة داخل المنطقة و
نعرض بعضًا من آخر
قاذفات صواريخ غراد متعددة الأسلحة الثقيلة
التي تم سحبها من
قادة المنطقة المنزوعة السلاح في سوريا الذين
تحدثنا إليهم هنا ، وقد سارعت في
التأكيد على أن هذا مجرد
سحب للأسلحة الثقيلة وأثناء
يأمل الجميع في أن تصمد هذه الاتفاقية ،
فهناك حقيقة جادة
وحقيقة أنه يتعين عليهم أن يجهزوا أنفسهم
للاحتمالات التي لا يحدث
ذلك ، ولكن يقول إيلاد إنها ستؤدي إلى
محيط من الدماء إذا لم تصمد هذه الاتفاقية
فهي بعيدة كل البعد عن  حل طويل الأمد
للتاريخ الدموي المأساوي الخطير ،
لكن المقصود منه على الأقل
السماح بفترة راحة من التفجيرات
والعنف التي مزقت العديد من
العائلات تخلق شعوراً
بالاستقرار وربما تسمح
فقط بحل سياسي قابل للتطبيق أروى
ديمون سي إن إن في المنطقة منزوعة السلاح
سوريا